okay guys who crime or pine night please
return and um I also want to state that
it get away to hurt stag I'm eating a
lot by others on the way out me now how
should I definitely love this way by
I'll fill you in okay I mean stag so
here's in showing you know what it is
like a baby don't try to hide that you
know what it is good good hmm well look
Pierce can read girl lion got explain
myself to you I want your to test a
touch stag is using nyteblayde as their
mascot you snatched a punk and we draw
stack set it up right I get the drop on
those on I'll focus mm-hmm Jimmy um
excuse me thank you sign this well [ __ ]
is this dude is Johnny's coming he sold
his likeness to aunt or they're making a
movie out of this year Oh mommy to call
legal aid services thank you alright so
how do we find Burke chump could be a
look we later right bait he'll come to
us that's why I need you in the new
stable my name's viola your name's the
bloody Canada's oh you can't be serious
worse for me haha I feel ready off
you're working the [ __ ] nun angle
better than I would trust me I didn't
get a masters in economics to look like
a [ __ ] what did you get a masters in
economics for my god I'm cook know if
it's out okay
ah vodka because we'll just take this
sweet ride huh oh yeah are we sure Burke
will even be at the pr center I met this
clown he's probably on set doing lying
face lemon face right now you're not
serious about his work no he's that
deluded about being nyteblayde it's a
sickness believe me um that's good you
know this make us Cyril then step bits
of cereal it's a steak that cops taking
a ball is there a plan as night blades
archenemies we act yeah me that milk
Chewie and I down it'll be quite simple
well we could say we have Sean D hostage
but that could just do it for you even
if you do put milk on you could put some
steak sauce in there yeah mix it in
maybe like a creamy steak sauce are we
good yeah
okay what the fuckis that's this the
mission she's like don't hit anyone okay
hmm drop your gun hidden uh somewhere
okay oh [ __ ] who are these box how do I
arch enemy nyteblayde yeah yeah go in
you flash a little skin we can probably
get into anywhere in the city careful
notes or not I'm not making going out
like this a habit have it oh that's too
precious I hate you mm-hmm una pursues
out way this looks like the right place
hey you guys want to do some warm-ups
for shoot you look familiar yeah really
love Tess come on Claud [ __ ] hot out
of here very subtle next time you punch
him it's very soon printer is like the
best just in the world
the show tell me fine and if he isn't
then I'll go back for like two whole
minutes cook [ __ ] socks here we go
okay is that part of to choke a cliche I
I think I fell you'll never stop me
[ __ ] hang
Burke can you say overkill publicity is
the key to taking a city some guns and a
few high explosives tend to get the job
done to it really worked out for you way
to kill the mood huh okay cast oh I'm
just a pretty face in script [ __ ] is my
partner okay come on cap okay I'm enter
the LA elevator now what next oh this
text then we keep heading down
mercia sketches hiding them you're
starting to hire them
well that's not a [ __ ] chair not bad
pistol but big cut what the [ __ ] must be
a way out of the garage there's a lot of
guys coming there we go
yeah imma get somewhere I'm o for this
[ __ ] all right [ __ ] have the wrong one
still there oh [ __ ] sorry of a steak
okay mmm this is this black might be a
vest proudly I guess we after this one
get in the car betch catch let's go we
get back to the crib and dumped in with
Pierce and Shaun be and if he waits that
with an outfit like that use your
imagination honey chill here
tipton help
no I barn great work guys I was classic
heels is straight up kidnapping right
what Billy do we need to spell it out
you're gonna get away with this
go go looking for me night latex
wanna make shonda showers do you shut
ins you I'll play your game yeah that's
pretty funny actually
hmm might have a mistake [ __ ] up go
check the bodies well I can't ask get me
Monica Hughes they have burst damn it i
assure you ma'am he'll get him back
thank you dicks out for Harambee